It's time for the moment you've been waiting for.
I
can go pretty low.
Excuse me.
Preparing the outfit reveal.
Yee-haw.
I mean, what were you guys expecting?
This is my true form, guys.
And I have a hat now.
Oh my god.
Is this height?
I also have like... my hat has physics too.
Woah.
Anyway.
I mean, I also have this hat too.
Okay, okay, okay.
Alright.
Sorry.
Anyway.
Presenting the real skinsuit debut.
Here is your champion.
Landing in Thadwood Canyon.
Round one.
First blood.
Now, time to fuck some dudes.
Oish.
Nice table.
Well, if the price is right, I'll do it alright.
Awww.
I'm a good guy.
Fuck you.
I'm
a good guy.
I'm the best.
I'm a good guy.
I'm such an asshole.
I get it, man.
That's a good name.
That's a good one.
You're a real good guy.
Yeah.
That's what I wanted to do down to.
How is it?
This is a crazy cool thing.
I
love this song.
So easy.
Oh yay!
Congratulations!
Dragoons!
You paid us!
$60 to unlock me!
Yes, me.
Alright.
Now you know why we went through six loops today.
You finally did it, Dragoons!
You've unlocked me.
The newest update.
The newest character in BattleBirds.
What do you mean scammed?
How could you say that?
It's me!
It's worth it.
I swear.
We all know when a new character gets released, it's like super OP and then they nerf it later after making people buy the character.
Because it has to be super OP so that people will spend $60 to buy to unlock the character because they want to win.
It's like a It's just pure scam.
It's pure capitalism.
But congratulations on spending that $60 guys.
Congratulations.
I need you to scroll me up though.
Oh, check out my boots.
Like that little shiny tints and little spurs.
Yeehaw.
I'm your Canadian cowboy.
Anyway, I guess we could move a little bit higher I guess.
Nothing really.
I don't know if anything is exciting as we get higher.
It's just legs.
It's legs from here.
But then we have the hand.
Woah.
You see?
You see how my hand fingers move too?
Guys?
Woah.
Oh yeah.
I can like bounce up and down as well.
Look at that.
Hahahaha.
I can move my hands too.
Oh and then my little belt is dangling.
Oh my gosh.
I don't know why.
I feel like I'm like, well technically I am sort of like re-debuting again.
Hahahaha.
How many?
How many re-debuts am I going to get?
God.
Hahahaha.
Yes.
Look at that.
Look at my belt.
Oh and the shadow too.
I need to make sure I don't accidentally press the wrong button.
Because like, if I press... there's a button here that I press that will take me straight to my face.
And like, I don't want to accidentally press that.
So...
I'm laughing more because I'm more nervous.
Hahahaha.
But yes.
You might see my color palette changed a little bit too.
So...
Oh and you might see an aviator as well at the top.
Alright, let's hope that I don't fuck this up.
But... Yeah!
Hahahaha.
I have a gun now.
But if like, uh, YouTube was like, no guns allowed, don't worry.
I can... I can hide it so they won't know.
If like, if I get striked by the TOS because I have a gun, I'll just be like...
I'll just be like, boop.
Hahahaha.
Yes.
Being a bounty hunter is hard work, guys.
I do have, uh...
I have scars on my...
on my other arm.
On my right arm.
Um...
Yes.
I also have a little...
a little belt here too.
To hold all my ammo because I always need light ammo.
Um...
I don't know why my main gun of choice is a deagle though.
Uh... Because we all know like... Hahahaha.
I'm not really good with the, uh...
the Doki Wing.
I'm not... I'm not the best at the Doki Wing.
So...
Um... It is a little awkward that that's my choice of gun.
But that means...
That means I'll get better!
The more I practice...
The better I'm going... Okay, it's not a deagle.
Sorry.
It's... Uh...
Hahaha.
It's a revol...
I'm sorry, guys.
It's a revolver.
Look!
I don't know much about gun names.
I just know gun...
I can... I can shoot the gun and people die.
That's it.
Look!
You paid... You did buy the collector's edition for the bounty hunter.
That's on you.
Uh... Hahaha.
Hahaha.
The... The collector's edition of...
Uh... The collector's edition of the bounty hunter would include a bounty hunter that knows the gun names.
But you went the cheap route.
You went for the $60 uh... standard edition of the bounty hunter.
That's why you only have one skin.
Okay?
You only have... If you bought the collector's edition uh... of the bounty hunter, the debut bounty hunter skin, you would have got the rare skin.
And that rare skin... That rare Doki bird bounty hunter skin would have known the gun names.
Hahaha.
That Doki bird would have known the different gun names.
Okay?
She would have known the gun that she was carrying.
Uh... Joke's on you guys.
You can't... You can't refund this.
You can't.
Hahaha.
And the T... Joke's on you.
This isn't Steam.
Hahaha.
It's Doki verse.
Doki verse does not provide any refunds.
So you will not get any refunds.
You like how I'm stalling so I won't let you guys see my face?
Cause I'm building up the anticipation.
You're like, what does she look like?
Hahaha.
Whoa!
Alright, let me move like one centimeter more and then go on with my tangent.
Anyway, uh...
Hahaha.
Yes.
Um...
You guys knew what you were gonna get in the Doki verse chat.
Doki verse chat does not provide any refunds.
What you buy is what you get.
Hahaha.
Yes!
I have a bandana now.
I actually used to have a bandana.
You know what I'm gonna say?
It's like a... Uh...
It's basically like a build up of my past, present, into a future.
Uh... When my very first skin suit actually wore a bandana.
Just like this.
So, uh...
This is like basically...
Um... Basically a tribute to my very fir... One of my... My very first skin suit had a bandana just like this.
Well, not just like this, but it was like similar colors and similar design.
Um...
Okay, anyway.
Uh...
Let me scroll... Let me move up a little bit.
Ooh!
Hahaha!
Now you see a little bit of the hair!
Alright, for those who are like, she's flat!
You have not seen the reference sheet yet.
Hahaha!
That's...
That's all I'm going to say.
Hahaha!
You... You have not...
You have not seen the reference sheet yet.
All... That's all... That's all I'm gonna say, okay?
Like... Look, I have... It's cause like everything is like...
It's like, you know...
Everything... It's like I could have like, you know, a sports bra.
You don't know that?
You know... Hahaha!
Hahaha!
Okay.
Anyway, guys.
Uh... Whoa!
Um...
We do have... We are missing the rest of the face, though.
Ooh!
Do I move one centimeter above?
Whoa!
Oh!
Hahaha!
Wait, I can... I can like...
fuck with you guys more.
A little bit.
Let me see.
Where is it?
Oh my gosh.
Is it this one?
Oh yeah!
Okay.
So I have a little feature that I can... I can like...
mess with you guys a little bit.
That comes with the uh... uh...
Bounty Hunter skin.
Which is...
Whoa!
Hahaha!
Wow!
I... When will we get... When will we see the face?
Oh my god!
When are we gonna see the face?
I don't know.
Hahaha!
Anyway.
Uh...
I feel like... Guys, when I do show... When... Ooh!
Hey, you guys can see the bottom of my...
You can see the bottom.
Hahaha!
I just need you guys... I just need you guys to know...
Um...
There's a lot of announcements...
After...
So... Because I know a lot of people are like, alright, saw the face.
Close tab.
Hahaha!
But... But there is... Ooh!
You see the feather here?
There is a lot of announcements...
Right after, guys.
Um... And by a lot, I meant there is a lot of announcements.
Hahaha!
Alright.
I feel like I have to zoom in a little though.
Because... Alright.
Boop, boop, boop, boop.
And we're gonna get to the face now.
Alright.
Are you guys ready?
Uh... Don't FOMO us.
I'm just telling you guys to stay a little longer!
That's what I'm... That's all I'm trying to say!
Alright.
Okay.
Are you guys ready?
I'm gonna do a countdown.
Okay?
I'm gonna... I'm gonna do a countdown now, guys.
Alright.
Five...
Four... Okay.
Actually...
I mean... Mess with you guys a little more too.
Uh... Hahaha!
Hahaha!
Alright.
There you go.
So it...
Your immersion will stay a little bit.
Alright.
Are you guys ready?
Five... Four...
Hahaha!
Five... Hahaha!
Four...
Hahaha!
Three...
Two...
Hahaha!
One...
Hello!
Everybody!
Hello, hello!
Yes!
This is what I look... This is my newest skin suit.
The Bounty Hunter.
Um...
Okay.
So, like...
I'm not used to be...
being so fluid and...
uh... articulated.
Hahaha!
On the box!
On stream.
Um... Because I... It's...
It's been a while.
Actually, no.
I've never had that experience before.
I've never...
I've never experienced...
like... being able to move so much in general, to be fair.
Hahaha!
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
So... Um...
One of my...
favorite features here...
for this one... is that...
I can do this.
Hahaha!
I...
I love... I love this expression the most.
Hahaha!
And... and...
Of course, I specifically requested that...
uh... I wanted this face too.
Hahaha!
Okay.
So, yes.
The smug is still there.
The smug is...
is still there.
But!
I also have...
a million different emotions.
Uh...
that I can do.
So...
Oh!
Yes!
How could I forget?
We've... The best...
Um... The best member on this channel...
Um...
He's back, guys.
Hahaha!
We got Dad...
We also stuffed Dad into his skin suit as well.
So, he's back as well, guys.
Now he can also be on stream with me!
Yeah!
Look at him!
He's so bouncy!
Dad is back!
He's a super long boy too.
Um...
But yes.
Uh...
We stuffed Dad into his very own skin suit as well.
Um... And he really prefers being in the skin suit now.
Because, like, he has bigger claws.
And he can... He can dig.
Hahaha!
He's a... He's a tracker.
So, um... If you don't know, like...
Like, I mean... It's pretty ironic because, like, Dad was originally a wiener dog.
And, uh... Now he's like...
You know... And they're really good at tracking people.
And... You know, in Bounty Hunter lore, uh...
We need someone to be able to track the people for money.
So I can, like, kill them and get money.
I mean, since it's dead or alive, obviously I'm gonna choose the dead part because it's just easier.
It means I get to carry less weight to the police.
So...
I feel like if it's dead or alive, it's 100% dead.
Because then I don't have to worry about, like, carrying cargo.
And, uh...
Hahaha!
And... It makes it easier because Dad can, uh... Doki Amber Doge can... Sorry.
Not a dog.
Not a doge anymore.
Doki Amber...
What are you?
Hahaha!
Yes!
What are you?
Hahaha!
Um... He is some form of dog.
We've discovered a new breed of dog.
Um...
And...
Alright, alright, Dad.
You...
You dropped down right now, Dad.
Wooo!
Alright.
Also, let me show you guys some of the, uh... expressions that I can do now.
Yeah?
Was it worth the... Are you guys okay?
That we waited a day for this debut?
Hahaha!
Are you guys okay with the weight?
Was the weight worth it?
Guys!
Hahaha!
Alright, so... Alright.
So...
You might have seen in my trailer video...
My, uh...
Gameplay trailer video...
That, uh... I can have aimbot eyes now.
So... So...
This time, I have legal wall hacks in aimbot.
So, surely my gameplay is gonna improve now, right?
And I can, like...
Zoom in.
I can ADS.
Uh... My eye has a special feature where...
I can ADS with my eye.
Hahaha!
So I'll be like, ADS time!
Um... But yes.
Uh... So, anytime I'm...
Anytime I'm losing, I'll just turn aimbot on.
But it's legal!
It's...
It's legal aimbot because it's part of my body.
Like, you can't report me if it's, like, part of my... If it's a biological aimbot.
Like, it's like how Bloodhound has legal wall hacks when he scans the walls.
So...
Since this is in my eye...
It's...
Legal aimbot, I say as I start downloading... Hahaha!
Hahaha!
Downloads aimbot but puts red eye on so people will be like, oh, she's just... She's just roleplaying, guys.
Like, it's part of her...
It's part of her lore and she's just...
She's just trying to make it immersive, guys.
Hahaha!
Alright.
Okay.
Another thing I have.
It's...
Oh...
What's... What's 2 plus 2?
Hahaha!
Dragoons, where am I?
Where do I go?
Hahaha!
I'm so lost!
Dragoons!
Okay.
This is another expression that...
I really like to make.
And it's this.
Hahaha!
Oh my god!
I love it!
The little...
That... It's like... It's like actual Doki bird.
The bird part.
Hahaha!
I'm so not used to it!
I can make faces I've never been able to make before.
So it's so weird being like...
I can... Okay.
So this is frowning.
But then I can do this.
Hahaha!
You know like the little...
The little teeth... Like mouth in front.
Like...
Hahaha!
Alright.
Okay.
Here we go.
And then... We have so many.
I have like 3...
Columns of this.
By the way.
I'll have announcements soon.
Announcements soon.
But I need to show you guys this.
Alright.
Anyway.
And then we have credits.
We have announcements.
We also have credits.
Uh...
My team of 30 plus people that worked so hard on everything.
Um... But also... Look at this though.
Oh!
Hahaha!
Oh my god!
Is that... Are you gonna...
You're offering me free stuff?
I love free stuff!
Hahaha!
I love free things!
You wanna offer me a collector's edition of Elden Ring for free?
I'm not gonna be playing the DLC.
But like for...
I'll take it!
Cause it's free!
Hahaha!
And then we also have... Alright.
This one is also tears.
Uh...
But...
Uh... I actually have tears dropping down.
See?
Woo!
Hahaha!
Tears are actually... actually dropping down on my face.
I also have...
Are you gonna play scary games?
Did you guys... Did you hear that?
Did you guys hear that?
What did you... What's that?
Hahaha!
Alright.
And... Alright.
You guys saw this already.
Alright.
So you know what was funny?
Um... What was funny?
Is that I didn't ask for this.
I asked for like...
3 expressions to be able to be made.
Uh... During my...
Uh... During my... For my new skin suit.
And... You know what was funny?
My mama...
Was like... When I was like...
Talking to my mama...
My mama was like... If you want me to...
Like... I didn't ask for... I didn't... I didn't say anything.
My mama was like...
If you want me to make the neck longer, I will for you.
Hahaha!
I thought I was...
I thought I was so funny!
And then... And then my papa...
Celia... Uh... She actually...
Like I didn't... I didn't ask her to.
I didn't ask my mama to do it.
But I thought it was just really funny.
And then... I swear... My mama and papa were on like the same...
With the same wavelength.
Because they were like... They... And then my...
My papa... Um...
She just put it in.
She just put it in herself.
Because I was like... Oh, that's so funny mama!
Hahaha!
And... Also I have this eyes too.
The sparkle eyes.
But not the extra... Uh...
The extra sparkles.
So if I just...
You know... I'm not as excited as the other one.
You know... This would be like super excited.
And then...
The other one would be like... Oh!
I'm... I'm...
I'm amused.
I'm amused guys.
Anyway...
Also... Okay... Some guys were wondering... Can I take the jacket off?
Yes, I can.
Look... Okay... Before you're like...
Oh my god!
She's flat.
Wait until I... You see the reference sheet.
Okay?
Hahaha!
Look...
I have to run a lot as a bounty hunter.
Okay guys?
And because of that, I have to put on a sports bra.
Okay?
People with sports bra... People... People with boobs would understand!
Hahaha!
People...
People with boobs would understand!
The... The parallels!
You do not want to... You do not...
You want a good sports bra when you're riding a horse!
You would understand!
Hahaha!
So true!
All I'm saying is that you can't have...
You have to have a sports bra on when you're riding a horse.
That's all I'll say.
That's all.
That's all I'll say!
Anyway... Jacket back on.
Uh... But yes, I can... I can take my jacket off.
And this is what... This is what it looks like.
Whoa...
Yes... And...
Uh... Another thing...
Oh yes!
I can wear my avi... I mean, of course I should be able to wear my aviators.
It's literally like... It's not like fucking sewn into my jacket.
Um...
This... I don't know if you guys would notice this, but...
Uh... The aviators...
Like this look...
The aviators part...
Because I really wanted aviators.
It was very inspired by... Uh...
Sniper from Team Fortress 2.
But like... The aviators part...
Hahaha!
I really... I really wanted aviators.
Because you know... You know like gamer...
Gamer... Gamer glasses?
That was a thing back then.
You know like those gamer glasses?
That was a thing like... Like 8 years ago.
Where they're like... You have to wear those like gamer glasses because it's gonna improve your performance.
And then it was also inspired by Sniper from Team Fortress 2.
Whatever happened to those gamer... The gunners!
Yes!
Whatever happened to the gunners?
Do they still exist?
Are they...
Are they still relevant?
I don't know.
I don't know if they're still relevant at all.
Um...
And... Um...
I don't know if...
Uh... If they're still...
They're still around.
But anyway...
Other than that... Uh...
Let me put my glasses away.
I can also...
Hmm...
Hahaha!
Oh... Fuck.
But yes.
If I'm like... I'm laughing too much.
I need to be relatable.
And like...
Show other emotions or they'll think I'm AI.
I can force my skin suit to frown for me.
So like... You know...
I'm like... Oh no!
They're gonna think...
They're gonna realize I'm actually...
Not real.
Because all I do...
All I do is just laugh.
And they're like...
No real person only laughs.
And only shows laughter as an emotion.
She might not be real.
And then I would just be like...
Don't worry.
I can also frown.
But like... I'll be forcing my skin suit to frown.
So they'll never expect it.
Hahaha!
Oh god!
It's so unnatural!
I just need to make sure I don't laugh when I say that.
Anyway...
Finally...
I have this.
I have the...
Oh my god!
Can I say... No!
I'm Indie.
I can say it.
I have mind break eyes.
I was like... Wait... Am I allowed to say...
Yeah.
I can.
Um...
I have... Yeah.
Soul-less eyes.
Sorry!
I meant soul... That's what I meant!
PG.
Soul-less eyes.
Soul-less...
Hahaha!
I have... I have...
I didn't request for these eyes.
It was given to me.
Um...
It was... It's... The soul-less eyes.
Yes!
That's what I mean!
The soul-less eyes.
That's exactly what I intentionally meant, guys.
I did not mean anything else.
That's what I meant, chat.
So yes!
Um...
That... Oh!
I can also take my clip off.
But I don't remember what number that was.
What was that number?
Is it... Okay.
We're gonna play around with the numbers now.
What could it be?
There's like so many numbers.
Whoa!
What did I put on?
Oh!
That's the soul-less eyes.
Yes!
There we go!
I can...
Okay.
Also like...
I...
I know some of you guys might have been like...
Wait!
That hair clip!
That's... Someone else has a similar hair clip as well.
I just want you guys to know that it was a huge coincidence.
It was a big coincidence because my mama actually put the hair clip... Like designed the... Designed the skin suit with that hair clip before... Um...
Before I talked to that one person that shared the similar hair clip.
And I remember I told... I told that VTuber I was like... Oh my god!
This was not intentional.
When I do this debut, it is not intentional.
My mama actually put that hair clip on by herself.
So...
Yes, I can take off the hair clip.
Anyway, those were all my... Um... The things I can do.
Anyway, uh...
Before I do announcement, let's go to the saloon.
Yes, the saloon.
Oh my god.
Alright, this is gonna be where we're gonna hang out now.
Guys, I love the saloon.
It's one of my favorite places to go to now.
Because... Okay, look in the back though.
Like...
Okay, but... Look at...
Look at the back over there.
Uh... There's two tomatoes?
You mean there's more than one?
Oh my god!
They're multiplying!
I think my favorite is that... Uh...
That chonky goon over there.
Make... Making those burlesque egg goons dance for him.
Like...
Okay, now that I said that out loud, it is absolutely more creepy than I realized when I said that out loud.
Um... But you know how like every saloon, there's like... There's like women there that would be like, hey there cowboy.
You want...
Look, they need to make money!
They need to...
They need to make money!
It's hard times out there.
Um... In the wild west chat.
It's hard times.
Um...
And I'm drinking my favorite drink.
Uh... Uh... Doking...
Uh... Fuck.
Okay.
Doking rum.
Yes.
From... From... Which I've made, obviously.
I own doking rum.
And so you guys should also buy doking rum.
And it invest in my... Invest in my product.
To the moon it goes.
Uh... Anyway!
Let's welcome my new chatting...
My new chatting area.
That I didn't break into this time.
I didn't break into.
Uh... I actually... You know, this is one of my favorite establishments to go to.
The little... The local saloon.
You know?
It's just my... My local saloon, guys.
Uh...
Oh, gosh.
I'm so...
I'm so nervous.
Alright!
Finally!
Before I talk about credits...
It's announcements time.
Before I give into details about...
You know, production credits.
And, um... All the concept arts.
And...
Um... Everything that went into it.
I have...
How many announcements do I have?
Two really...
Really big announcements.
And I...
I am gonna go with the smaller one first.
So, I asked if I could announce this one.
Oh, yeah.
By the way, I have a... Oh, by the way.
Sorry.
Nevermind.
Merch.
First off...
Merch!
Before I talk about the announcements, I have a new logo now!
And also, merch is up!
Yes!
Debut merch!
Uh, if you go to Doki Merch right now, you can pre-order uh, the new acrylic stand!
Drawn by my mama!
Who I will... Obviously, I feel like you guys already know who my mama is.
But I will reveal my mama!
In like, woah!
Like, who's your mama?
Don't play fucking dumb with me.
I know you all know.
Anyway...
Yes!
Drawn by my mama!
And my mama will also be drawing a huge illustration later.
But like, we couldn't get it done in time.
But!
They finished the acrylic stand!
The key visual!
Um...
Alright, I'm gonna pin my mod.
My mod, can you...
Can you write that message again?
Chat's going so fast, they didn't...
Chat's going so fast, they don't realize I'm a cowboy.
Uh...
But yes!
New merch is out!
There's gonna be even more merch that's coming out on my birthday!
Because we weren't able to set all of it up in time.
So...
Um...
For now, we only have debut merch right now!
Uh... But yes!
I'll put this away for now.
Anyway, new merch!
Anyway!
First announcement!
Oh, which one?
Alright, let me pin... I'm gonna pin SilentSweeper because the link is first.
Okay, first announcement.
Um...
I will be on the Gamersupps V-Card Trading Cards.
So, if you guys do not know, Gamersupps is...
Gamersupps is releasing VTuber cards.
VTuber trading cards.
And I will be part of the V-Card collection.
This is also why I chose this week to reveal my skin suit because people were gonna be sent my cards like next week.
So I was like, oh fuck, okay.
Because I had a decision on whether or not, like, people were gonna be given like early access.
So I had a decision on whether or not if I should wanted to use my old skin suit or my new skin suit.
And I chose, I decided to choose the new skin suit because I was like, yeah, fuck it.
That should... I... fuck it.
Let's go.
Anyway, I am also allowed to show you guys the sketches.
The illustrations are finished.
But...
I do have the sketches here.
So we have the main art illustration.
This is the sketch by the way.
It's not the finished because I'm keeping the finished versions like...
Not secret but like when it's released you guys would be able to see the finish but it's just more or less a teaser.
So this is the sketch for the full art.
And then this is...
Sorry.
This is the sketch.
For...
For the other one.
And...
And then finally we have one for...
One for the dragoons too.
So here are... Here's the dragoons version as well.
So I've seen the finished copies of all of them.
And it's sick as fuck.
The reason why I'm green is that I am a grass type because I'm a bird.
So it made sense.
I mean they don't have the fucking wild west type, you know?
So...
I don't know.
It was like water, fire, grass, electric.
And then we were like well dragoons...
Because we had to make it based off of like where you're...
There's no flying type.
I would have chosen flying type if there was.
So... And like you know my true form is a tomato in the end.
So like obviously um...
Obviously, you know, since my true form is a tomato, it would make sense for me to be a grass type.
Because that's my true form.
Alright!
The biggest announcement!
Um...
Which I feel like some of you guys have predicted already.
Um... I might as well just show you guys the video.
Alright.
So my biggest announcement...
is...
Oh!
What's it gonna be?
It is...
Yeah!
That's right!
We're gonna have a PC case!
Yes!
That's based off of my new skin suit!
I think the black and gold looks fucking amazing in the back.
Not gonna lie.
The black and gold really works um...
super well.
Um...
But yes!
You will be able to see this at Anime Expo!
Um...
On July 4th to whenever Anime Expo ends.
And there's not just a PC case.
This is basically a teaser for the other products.
We worked with Hyatt and iBUYPOWER to design...
I put a lot of...
I put a lot of like...
I guess... What's the word?
A lot of my input on it.
On various things.
Various products.
With Hyatt and um... iBUYPOWER.
And um...
Oh my gosh!
I cannot wait for you guys to see it.
I cannot wait for you guys to see the other merch line with them.
But!
Yes!
At Anime Expo, you guys will be able to see the products there.
And I think... I don't know if you're allowed to touch it.
But...
Um...
That is why... That is like...
One of the hype things in July.
I don't know if you guys know this.
But... If you guys don't follow me on Twitter.
But I talked about how...
Um... How...
The beginning of... Not just the beginning.
The month of July.
There's gonna be...
A lot of announcements.
And a lot of things that's gonna be happening.
In July.
And like...
The Hyatt thing is only one of them.
And... Because I was like...
Oh my gosh!
A lot of my dreams are coming true.
It's not just a PC case.
There's so much more.
And that's why I also have not done a goals list.
At all.
Because...
Um... If I do the goals list.
I'm gonna spoil some of the future announcements.
So...
I've been keeping it in.
And being like... Oh I can't talk about...
I can't talk about...
Like...
I can't put it as a goal!
Because I'm gonna get it!
And...
And that includes...
A PC case.
And I'm so happy because...
Um...
A PC case has been a dream of mine.
For like... Not just like a PC case.
I'm so happy that it is finally becoming a reality!
I'm really happy.
And I know so many Dragoons have been waiting for a really long time for this.
And I know that despite you guys have evolved into birds now, I hope you're still excited for this PC case.
And I specifically requested that I wanted Dragoons to be a part of my merch line.
So all the merch stuff that they're releasing includes the Dragoons.
Because they're like, do you just want you or do you want to have other stuff?
I was like, I want that in there and the Dragoons.
And they're like, okay, which form?
I was like, I want all the Dragoons!
All types of Dragoons have to be in there!
So I specifically...
Because I couldn't have made it this far or got here without you guys.
And without your support and everything.
So that's why I've always wanted to include you guys into my...
As many merch line or sponsors and stuff.
Because I want you guys with me!
I want you guys with me on these things.
And I also designed some of the...
I guess I gave a lot of input and design for the merch line as well.
So you're going to see some products and I can talk...
When the products are finally out, I can finally talk more about what I added.
And what I gave my input on.
Because we worked really hard.
It was like a lot of back and forth for it.
So...
What else did I want to say?
About the PC case.
Yes, you guys can finally own a triangular PC case.
Oh my god!
Finally, you can match with me!
I have a triangular PC case too!
Oh yes, by the way.
Doki Merch now ships to Indonesia.
We did it guys.
We fucking did it.
Because I know...
Like before we didn't have Indonesia as one of the shipping profiles.
But by the way, we've added Indonesia into Doki Merch.
So now you can...
Now you can buy Doki Merch products.
And have it shipped to Indonesia.
Yes, now you guys can own a triangular PC case.
Yes, you can match with me!
You guys can finally match with me.
Chat.
Okay.
Anyway.
There's also...
Is there another announcement?
I have another announcement.
Alright.
Oh yeah, like I said.
Um...
There is like...
Uh...
A lot of my future announcements coming in as well.
So...
You guys might be like, oh is that it?
Is that...
I mean, that's a lot of stuff.
But...
I'm gonna fatten you up, dragoons!
Feeding you every month!
But yes.
There is more announcements.
More announcements coming in.
I think like...
Either next week or...
I think like either next week or July.
Beginning of July.
Or July 4th.
I think.
On my birthday.
I think it was on my birthday.
I don't remember.
Uh...
But you guys have to wait.
You guys have to wait two more weeks, guys.
Two more weeks!
And then you can finally figure out what it is!
Alright.
I have a list of things I have to do regarding this showcase.
But first off, we gotta thank the project team for their incredible hard work on all of this.
Um...
I was looking at my chat while the entire thing was playing.
And you guys were like, Oh my god!
No wonder you had to delay it!
And I was like, Oh thank god.
Now they realize why.
I was like, You guys have to see it to see why it was delayed!
When you see it, you will know!
Alright.
To the credits we go!
Alright!
Yes.
First off.
We are gonna go...
Okay.
I can actually be able to move myself.
We are gonna go with...
Obviously...
Uh...
My new mama.
And...
Um...
I feel like it was the worst kept secret.
The moment you're like, The hands!
Um...
But...
Oh my god.
I am very happy to have Kamame to be my new mama for my new skin suit.
Um...
I was really happy about it.
I remember talking to them and being like, Are you interested?
And they were like, Of course!
Yes!
I really wanna do it!
And then...
You know...
It was like instant.
And then so...
Um...
I'm really happy to be able to work with Kamame, Tsugogo...
As my mama.
Um...
Because, you know...
They...
Uh...
Alright.
This is gonna get emotional.
This is gonna get mushy.
I hope my mama isn't figuring out how to translate this.
Um...
On...
On this part.
Um...
But...
Uh...
Basically...
The reason why I...
I wanted to go...
Uh...
With...
This artist...
As...
Uh...
My...
New mama...
Is...
Because...
Uh...
I really wanted to make them proud...
Of me...
As one of their newer Vtuber children.
Because I felt like I wasn't really able to in the past.
And I didn't really have a lot to give to them in the past.
To show my efforts.
And...
I didn't really want to show my efforts...
Or accomplish much...
Or really be a good Vtuber child.
So this is sort of like...
Round two.
This is like...
Round 2.
For...
And...
Um...
I really wanted to accomplish...
Uh...
So much more.
And...
Have them see...
All of these...
Sponsors...
And merch...
That I'll be getting in the future...
With their design.
Uh...
To make up for not having much in the past or being a little bit of a disappointment.
So...
I just want... and that's why...
I really wanted to go with them as my mama.
Because I wanted to make up for everything.
And I've really, really loved...
All the stuff they've done.
And they've always been super, super, super supportive.
And I just really want to make them proud of me.
And that's why I...
Went with them as my new mama.
And...
Yes, this will be...
My new skin suit.
But that doesn't mean my old one won't be used anymore.
Or stop being part of me.
We are gonna call it...
Retro Doki.
Because...
Retro Doki...
Has...
A lot of stuff coming out in the future.
Because...
Some sponsors and...
Some merch line that's coming up.
They specifically requested that they really would like to have Retro Doki be a part of it.
And I agreed because, you know...
I'm more known as Retro Doki than I am current...
Yeehaw Doki.
And so...
Retro Doki is staying around.
I might not be using the skin suit.
Like, often maybe like 1-2% or like, I don't know, 5%?
I don't know.
But...
We made a lot of memories with Retro Doki.
With the Retro Doki skin suit.
And like, Clea was an absolute great mama.
And...
Um...
Clea actually had a hand with like, designing.
Uh...
Working together with...
With New Mama.
Regarding...
I'll show you guys the sketches.
I'll show you guys all the...
We went through so much.
I didn't know what the fuck I wanted.
Um...
I didn't know what I really wanted.
So...
Um...
We went through so many...
Design concepts.
Before we finally settled to Bounty Hunting.
And I'll show you guys...
Uh...
What it looks...
What all the concepts and everything.
Because...
Um...
New and Old Mama were both...
Said yes to me showing...
Uh...
Concept art for everything.
So I'll show you guys after the credits and everything.
Anyway!
Um...
Anyway...
Uh...
Yes!
Celia...
We've announced this...
Uh...
During the charity.
Celia was the papa.
Um...
She did an amazing job.
Because...
She did a very good job with this.
Like She just...
She just did the best!
Like...
She just did.
I haven't really done a very.
The ...
That I've done a very.
Like...
Uh...
I think that...
I'm not used to being super duper fluid.
Oh my god.
Anyway.
I'm gonna butcher your name, but I'm just gonna say Cho.
Did the assistance and everything with helping Celia.
Bye!
My true form!
Rice Diet-y is my true form.
They also updated my true form.
They added more...
They show me new accessories.
If you don't know who Rice Diet-y is, they are really...
They're famous Vocaloid artists.
And created Shrimp Miku.
And they gave me a new hat.
They gave me new hats.
And they like, pushed some new bones into me.
So they updated my...
My bone structure and stuff within the tomato form.
So I'll show you guys when we're at the green screen.
Oh sorry.
When we're at the magenta screen.
I don't wanna take risks.
But when we're at the magenta slash purple screen.
I will show you the new updates to my true form that Rice Diet-y gave me.
It's not just a hat.
There's like many other things.
Oh my god.
Okay.
The funniest thing about my true form.
Is that they originally gave me Jiggle Physics.
But like, as a tomato.
It was so cursed.
I had... I had... I had Boob Physics on the tomato.
And I was like, oh my god.
Okay.
I don't know.
And I asked... I asked to... I asked to limit that.
I'll show you guys later.
I'll show you guys.
I was a very sloshy tomato.
Anyway.
Alright.
Let's on to like...
Um...
The stream assets.
Alright.
Uh... We have a new logo!
New ol' logo.
The creator of this new logo.
Wow!
Guys, please don't steal my logo.
Please don't...
Please don't screenshot and steal my logo.
Cause it was not supposed to be that HD.
Anyway.
So...
We have a new logo now.
Yes!
A new logo!
Um...
And it is made by the creator of my very first logo.
The logo you see... I don't know if it's on the store...
If it got taken off the store yet.
Oh yeah.
I can wink by the way.
Um...
But...
Uh... We have a new logo.
And this would be my future logo.
To represent Bounty Hunter me.
And this was actually made by the creator of my very first logo.
Uh... The one that I've been using everywhere.
Uh... By the way, I have no new headers.
No new schedule overlay.
Uh...
No new... Like... I don't...
I did not invest in that.
I'll do that later.
There was other priorities.
Anyway.
The reason why I didn't invest on all those other graphics is because like...
I only let a very, very limited amount of people know what I was gonna look like.
And because of that...
I didn't invest in all those other graphics.
I had to pick and choose who was gonna know what I was gonna look like.
Because the project team...
Only a very limited amount of people in the project team actually knew what I was gonna look like.
All the others were just given like a silhouette.
But those who had to work closely with what I look like now...
I DMed them directly and being like...
This is...
This is what it's gonna look like.
Because like I didn't... You know I'm an indie now.
And I was like... Oh my gosh.
I don't wanna make...
So many contracts.
Because I have to...
I have to pay my lawyer.
Uh...
Every time.
For a contract.
So...
I didn't wanna...
Do like 500,000 NDAs.
So I was just like...
I trust you to not...
I trust you guys.
So the more people I give it to...
The more likely it's gonna get leaked.
Because I was like...
Bro I don't...
I've already spent so much money.
I don't want this to get leaked.
I spent so much.
I don't want this skin to get leaked.
So yes.
We won't have...
We will get the assets later.
And...
I'm gonna go back to the...
Anyway.
I'll show you the back up logo though.
The back up logo we had.
That was made by...
SugarType.
I've always worked with SugarType a lot for logos.
And let me...
Oh my gosh.
Where is she?
I forgot.
I don't know where I saved it.
Give me a sec guys.
I'm a professional.
Alright.
I'll show you guys the back up logo.
Because by the way.
My first logo.
The reason why they're anonymous.
Is because they're planning on making a new account.
And they want it to be...
They don't want us to link to their old account.
Because...
The reason why I have a back up logo.
Was because...
This person that I've commissioned.
For the first logo.
That person was MIA for 3 years.
So I did not expect them to be back.
So I had a back up logo.
MIA.
Just in case.
Because I was like...
I really wanted my first logo.
MIA by my original logo artist.
Because I really love their logo.
So I asked SugarType.
If they could edit a back up logo.
In advance.
Alright.
Please don't steal this logo too.
But this is what the back up logo.
Looks like.
So like...
As like the interim logo.
So...
This is the...
This was the back up logo.
And I still...
I wanted to show you guys.
When I commissioned SugarType.
For this logo.
I let her know that it was going to be a back up logo.
Because I did one...
I didn't want just like an edited version.
Of my old logo.
But it was just...
I wanted to have as like an interim.
Like a place holder.
Until I find someone to make my newer logo.
And I didn't want to do that anymore.
But yes.
This is the back up logo.
But this is the main logo.
So I will be using this.
But I had it just in case.
But this will be my new logo.
It reminds me of...
Dragon Ball Z somehow.
It reminds me a little bit of Dragon Ball Z.
Anyway.
My chat overlay.
It is Sig.
And they've made...
A lot of chat overlays.
A lot of my chat overlays.
Over the years.
So it's not really a surprise.
And then...
I worked with a new artist.
It was a recommendation from one of my older artists.
You might recognize.
Um...
This is actually like...
I had a great time working with this artist.
Name.
Because the background looks amazing.
I actually...
It blew me away.
My instructions I gave to them was that...
I wanted to have a Saloon background.
And I wanted to be based off...
Some of the sketches.
Related to the splash art from the game.
The fake game.
Um...
And...
It was a recommendation from another background artist.
That I used to work with a lot.
From Shigo.
Who recommended Name to work with me.
Because their calendar was fully...
Booked.
So then I was like...
You know what?
I'm going to take a shot.
I trust your recommendation.
So yeah!
Hahaha!
Me flew!
It was the ending screen.
This is why yesterday I did not show the ending screen.
My usual ending screen.
Because yesterday I was...
I already swapped it to...
Like you know...
To my new skin suit ending screen.
And so I was like...
Alright we're not going to...
I need to make sure...
I don't accidentally show it.
Wooo!
Hahaha!
And that's why we had a little...
A bit of a different thing.
Also!
E-votes!
Yes!
I commissioned...
Claire and one of my...
Really good friends.
We've been friends for 15 plus years.
That lazy rat.
We've been friends since...
We were little.
So...
That lazy rat.
They've gone through a lot of...
You might recognize them as either...
Ken or Kuro.
We've been friends for like...
15 plus years.
They had many accounts.
Hahaha!
I worked with them with emotes and...
Like in our past...
As artists and stuff.
I've known...
I've known Ken...
Longer...
Than Gumi.
Hahaha!
Um...
And so...
We're gonna...
Also like... rats' emotes...
Were needed to edit because...
They were like...
Oh I thought you had one glove on.
I was like... No it's two gloves.
So they sent me the fixed version.
But I didn't have time to make a graphic for it.
But!
You might recognize these emotes.
Because they were my favorite emotes.
Hahaha!
Monkey is back!
Um...
We have... Monkey is back.
And so...
Yes the gloves... It's supposed to be two gloves.
Two... But then like...
He read the reference sheet wrong.
So...
Hahaha!
Um...
So like...
I have the edited version of it.
And so I'm gonna swap it back.
Like I'll... I just was too lazy to make a new...
Uh...
They sent me the fixed version while I was streaming.
So like I couldn't fix it.
You know?
There's also a reason why we don't have...
We're not gonna be like super fast with changing emotes.
Because like I said...
I was worried of leaking...
I was worried of the...
Worry of my skinsuit getting leaked.
So I just like commissioned like...
You know...
My old mama and one of my best friends.
Um... And being like...
Alright...
We'll get these emotes for now.
It's why I haven't updated my emotes.
Because I want to slowly swap my emotes to...
Um...
To my...
New skinsuit and stuff.
So yes!
Ship is back!
Finally!
Now you guys can spam the ship every time.
I was like thank you for the five gifted ships.
But I'll be adding these...
I don't know... Tomorrow or today.
Depending on how dead I am.
Today!
Depending on how dead I am today.
Um... Alright.
Next credit.
Where's my slideshow?
Where is it?
Alright.
Alright!
Stream assets!
We're not at the team yet.
We're not at the project team yet.
But yes!
We had four different...
Composers composing songs.
Because I wanted variations...
Of the music tracks...
And everything.
And so...
Huge shoutout to all those composers!
I was like, are you guys able to do it?
And they were like, YEAH!
And so... huge shoutout.
NowNor actually made my original...
BGMs for RetroDoki.
And I asked if they were free.
And then I decided...
Because I like... I wanted to experiment with...
Working with different composers.
And then like... you know...
Just experiment with different composers.
And different styles and stuff.
Because it helps.
Usually when I work with somebody...
I always go back to them.
So I like working...
Like finding people that I'm like...
Alright, I really like this style.
I have a project in mind.
That will fit this style.
So it helps a lot.
I don't know if you guys know this.
But I tend to work with the same people...
A lot when it comes to projects.
Because like... you know...
We've already had experience together.
And I trust them.
I worked with a lot of new people for this one.
As you guys can see.
Like 30 plus people.
I worked with a lot of new people.
So...
Naonor, Zefisona...
Eya...
And Athoril...
Composed most of the music for it.
We actually have somebody in the...
Main project team.
That composed some of the game music too.
So...
The video...
The Spongebob reference.
Hahaha...
Was done by one of my shorts editors.
Nashe124 He did the Tamayo reveal.
And the great...
Sorry I'm blocking your name right now.
The great Kaitsu...
Did the voice acting.
I was like...
I gave the video...
I was like Spongebob.
Hahaha...
They've done voice acting for...
Various other things I've done.
So like the...
Voice actor.
Whenever I have an idea.
Cause I was like...
Well your voice actor.
And you have a really big range.
And uh...
I'm gonna go with you for any future projects I have.
Related to voice acting.
And I need male voice number one.
Hahaha...
Anytime I was like...
I need male voice number one.
I hit him up.
Cause he's like the best.
He did the...
Batman one for us.
In the past.
And so...
By the way he sent me like three versions.
It got longer and longer and longer.
Cause at one point he was like...
The more you don't respond the longer I am gonna make this.
So then I took all of them.
And then I just sent it to my editor.
And was like alright I don't know.
Just pick one.
Hahaha...
Um...
Yes he did the Batman short.
He was the voice actor for the Batman short.
And then RetroVis!
I love working with RetroVis for my teasers!
It's so good.
It's so creative.
I love their style when it comes to teaser videos.
And um...
I will always...
If I ever have a chance I will always work with RetroVis.
When it comes to like...
Videos like this.
Um...
But yes...
That is the assets.
I think after that is the project team.
Project team!
Alright!
Management!
Alright so these were the people who were...
In charge of like...
Because there were 30 plus people I couldn't be...
On the server 24-7 obviously.
So...
We had a day a day channel for me that was like...
By the way!
Behind the scenes stuff.
I will be talking about behind the scenes stuff.
On Tuesday.
The day after cause like tomorrow I'm taking a break.
Hahaha...
Usually I don't stream on Sunday.
But on Tuesday I will be...
Talking about behind the scenes of everything.
Giving you guys the work in progress shots.
Of all the work in progress stuff.
And everything that goes into it.
Um...
Before I want to talk about the project team.
Before I talk about this.
I want to say uh...
The project team has worked...
Incredibly...
Incredibly hard on this.
We had...
The reason why we had 6 plus loops.
Is because I had additional notes that I had to give.
Regarding the audio.
Um...
So like they were like last minute rendering and stuff.
The video I sent there was like a lot of sound effects were missing.
And I noticed that.
And so we had to add sound effects and stuff.
Um...
And uh...
Cause I really wanted to have the immersive feeling of a video game.
Like you're actually...
Like it's not just a regular video.
Like you're actually in a made up video game.
That I fucking created.
Like...
That was in my head.
So...
Um...
This is actually like the most I've ever recorded for a project.
And...
It was the most expensive to date.
I won't say how much it cost.
I'll leave that in the member stream one day.
And I'll have a trigger warning.
Trigger warning.
Financial Irresponsibilities.
Hahahaha.
So...
Um...
And because of that...
I really wanted to...
Give like a huge shout out to them.
Also for putting up with me.
Um...
Because I was like...
I have more notes.
Hahahaha.
So...
I'm sorry if I was super blunt.
Sometimes.
But when I get overworked...
Not overworked.
When I get overwhelmed.
I've been really stressed out lately.
I don't fluff my words at all.
I just go like...
Fix this.
Hahahaha.
But yes...
Um...
Nova, Wisteria, Mr. Lex in the management team.
As well as project director was Nova.
Um...
And we have OnlyPilot.
Who you might recognize.
Because I've worked with OnlyPilot.
A lot.
A lot, lot, lot.
For a lot of my projects.
And honestly their graphics is like...
One of my favorite styles.
In terms of their graphics.
And they did the production lead and GUI.
I messaged...
A guild.
For this.
Because I message...
Rigor Mortis.
If you guys know the guild.
And they compiled majority of the people.
That's part of the team.
I brought in 3D people.
Um...
Because I had lots of experience.
Working with the 3D...
Uh...
Team.
And...
I personally...
I DM'ed the guild.
Mortis Guild.
And a lot of these people come from the Mortis Guild.
That were recruited into this.
And it was a huge team.
Because I was like...
Money.
Don't worry about how much it costs.
I was like...
Don't worry about the budget.
They were like... What's the budget?
There is no budget.
So bring in as many people as you want.
Um...
Because this was very ambitious.
You guys can tell.
It was so ambitious.
I've had this idea for the longest time.
This idea has been...
Something I had for a year now.
It's been an idea.
So I'm really happy.
I can finally implement it.
Hahahaha.
Anyway.
Pionee did the GUI logo.
So like the logos you see.
Like Doki Burst and the game icons.
And everything.
Um...
I'm really happy with the logos.
Alright.
Next slide.
Uh...
Wooo!
The art team!
I brought in some of the artists as well.
You might recognize a lot of these artists.
Uh...
That worked on this.
By the way.
I was going to tell this later.
But...
The splash art you guys saw.
The splash art will be free to download.
Later.
In the community post.
On YouTube.
So...
Did I usually make it on the community post?
Or just give you guys a link?
I'm going to tweet out the link.
All the splash arts you guys saw.
From the fake game.
Will be made into free wallpapers.
For all you guys.
The animation on the other hand.
Just like usually.
Like in the past.
The animation frames.
If you want to use any of the animation frames.
As a wallpaper.
That would be member locked.
Exclusive for members.
Regarding animation frames.
If you have a particular frame that you want.
To be made into a wallpaper.
I will be uploading those frames.
Animation frames.
HD quality of that.
In members.
But the splash art.
The ones you saw in the loading screens.
Like the alt girl doki.
Like the tomato.
The holding the tomato.
All of that.
That is free.
Those will be free.
3D models that you saw.
Except for the skins.
The dragoon skins.
That are based off of my friends.
Those are not going to be for download.
Because some of them are like corporate.
So I don't own them.
But the regular dragoons.
Retro doki.
Retro retro doki.
The tomato.
There is actually a tomato model made as well.
Those 3D models.
Will all be free to download.
Those will be free to download.
Then I will tweet about it later.
So yes.
Look at all of these artists we recruited.
I really wanted to have like.
An actual game feel.
Like I spared no expense.
I wanted to be a game feel.
So like you see.
Cho, Xtrident, Niko.
Pursuit, Tai, Kleia.
Kuno.
Data the splash art.
The loading screen art.
Then we had Shigo.
That did the Shio.
That did the character artist.
The character select that you saw.
For like doki, lunar new year doki.
Altagirl doki.
And then we had.
Black VT who did the icons.
The character select icons.
I believe.
And then Honey who did the sprays.
And the sticker art.
Also huge shout out for Honey.
Because they did a lot of like.
Shio.
There's a lot of like.
They did like additional stuff.
Because Shio also did the billboard art as well.
And then Honey I had like requests.
Like maybe like three days.
Two days before the stream.
I'd be like can we have a sticker of doking.
It would be so good.
Like I would love to have it.
And then they were like I got you.
And they literally drew it in like less than a day.
And they added the doking sticker.
Because I would be like oh I really.
Because like okay at one point.
I had like a sticker.
And then Honey sent me.
Like a really supportive DM.
Before my.
My.
New model.
New skin suit debut.
And because of that I asked if they could also make a new sticker.
For Jack Jesus.
Because I was like oh that's so sweet.
I was like hey can I ask to have a sticker.
Of Jack Jesus too.
.
So huge shout out to Honey.
For like accommodating that.
Like they could have said no.
And I would have been like okay.
.
But they were like don't worry.
Don't worry I can do it.
Alright.
3D team you're going to recognize a lot of these names.
I recruited.
I brought in a 3D team.
Well I brought in Jules.
Because I love working with Jules.
I brought in Legends.
Oh wait I brought in Jules and Squid.
I hit up Jules, Squid and Hask.
And um.
And I was like alright.
Bring in any of our old 3D team.
Into.
Oh my gosh.
Alright this is going to be awkward.
I'll be here.
I was like bring in any of our old 3D team in.
Um.
Um in.
Whatever you guys think that will work.
And then they brought in the rest of the people here.
So we've worked with Hask.
We've worked with all of these guys.
The newest addition is.
Isaac and Violet.
Violet did the Retro Doki.
You know like I really wanted it as an inside joke.
I was like I want Retro Doki in there.
I want Retro Doki but like.
Retro Retro.
Like Playstation 1 polygons.
And I brought in.
Low poly.
I brought in Violet.
I need this.
And then yeah Violet made it.
Isaac was our 3D animator.
And also I think the one with the most.
Apex knowledge.
So Isaac was like don't worry guys.
Like.
Like they were like giving.
Like ideas and input.
Regarding trying to make it more like Apex slash Overwatch.
So they helped a lot.
With like giving like.
Critiques and stuff.
And being like okay the GUI should look like this.
The graphics should look like this.
Similar to how Apex does it.
Like all that stuff.
But Isaac fully animated.
Everything that you saw.
Regarding.
Regarding the gameplay footage.
So like huge shout out to Isaac.
They were a new person.
I've never worked with before.
But I saw their animation and I was like.
Okay that looks sick.
This is my vision.
Do you think you can make it?
By the way Isaac animated this.
So fast.
Because like the 3D team finished all the.
Models.
For the fake gameplay footage.
I think on the 10th.
I believe.
I think it was the 10th or not.
The 3D team can fact check for me.
But they finished the.
The set.
The games like setting the.
Environment and everything.
On either the 10th or 13th.
I don't remember.
And then Isaac just animated.
All of that within like 10 days.
Which was fucking crazy.
That they were able to do that.
Um anyway.
So yes.
Jewels, Legends, Isaac, Violet, Hask.
Cart, Squid and Stilted Fish.
Huge shout out to the 3D team.
For those who are wondering.
Is that it?
What are you going to do with 3D world?
This world will be turned into a VR chat world.
In the future.
I was actually in talks.
With one of the VR chat.
Staff.
Um and.
It's not going to be instant.
Literally I was like.
Alright after all of this is done.
Our next.
When you guys relax a little bit.
There's no deadline for this one.
But like we will turn.
Dadwood Canyon.
By the way.
They gave me name suggestions.
I think one was like Dad Canyon or something.
And then the other one was like.
I was researching Wild West.
I was like alright what.
What do we have in the Wild Wild West.
And then it's like.
10 of the most famous.
Famous places in America.
Related to the Wild Wild West.
And then I was like.
It was like what Deadwood.
It was like Deadwood City or something.
And I was like.
Dadwood Canyon.
I was like.
I'm going to put wood.
That's like a reference.
To famous.
Famous.
Western city.
It works.
Also.
Remember Goons would be like.
So that's why she was asking us for game names.
Alright so.
A while ago.
I think like two months ago.
Or a month and a half ago.
I was like hey guys.
Give me a game name.
Because I need help.
This is going to be a wallpaper.
Theme.
For.
This is going to be a wallpaper theme.
For like a future month.
And I was thinking up.
I wanted to figure out a fake game name.
And then I fooled you all.
It was actually for this.
That's where I stole BattleBots.
From a member.
I was like.
Great name.
And I was like hey guys.
Look at this cool name.
I like came up with.
My self project.
I was actually waiting for the wall.
We have five wallpapers.
I don't even know.
We have like five to six free wallpapers.
One wallpaper.
You get five to six free wallpapers.
Now.
Anyway.
Like I said.
This world that we.
This team.
I'm a producer.
So I just chucked money at it.
But I did give feedback.
This game.
This world.
This 3D world.
That we made for a fake game.
Will be made into a VRChat world.
In the future.
Like I said.
It's not going to be something that's done really fast.
Because converting into a VRChat world.
Is a lot different.
Than.
It was not intentionally made to be a world.
But I figured.
Because I was talking to a staff member.
At VRChat.
Because they reached out to me.
And was like.
Hey do you ever want to do anything with VRChat in the future?
Let us know.
And I was like.
I really want to open a world.
Is it for free?
And they were like.
Yeah.
It's for free.
And I was like.
Woo!
I love it when it's for free.
I can open the world for free.
And I was like.
Can I have it up forever?
Yeah.
You can.
For free?
Yeah.
Woo!
So whenever this world.
Whenever this world.
Is done.
It will be there forever.
Alright.
What else?
I have 16 slides.
Oh my god.
This is slide 7.
The animation motion team.
Alright.
First off.
We have to applaud.
Bullied.
I'm so sorry.
We need to applaud you.
But I'm butchering your name.
They were the main editor.
For the video.
To put everything together.
And the one where I had notes for them.
Regarding sound design.
And I was like.
Fix sound design.
They put all the videos together.
They had.
They pulled off.
2 to 3 all nighters.
To put all of.
To try and finish this.
And we really need a.
Like huge.
Also you guys can see this poster.
I'm sorry.
I don't have ADHD.
I just need you guys to look at this poster.
Um.
So anything.
I feel like.
Bullied really does deserve a lot of love.
And attention.
And I was like.
Really blunt to.
To them.
During the prod.
Like yesterday.
I really apologize.
And um.
We were all stressed out.
Um.
And uh.
We really need to give a huge applause.
Love to the video editor.
To the main editor.
That put all of this together.
Um.
Cause like.
I wasn't in the server.
I'm not in the server.
I'll join back the server later.
When I'm like.
I was like.
Okay I'm gonna join back the server later.
So my staff was helping me.
Coronate and stuff.
Um.
And um.
My staff was like.
Giving me updates on everything.
While I was preparing.
Just like preparing for the stream in general.
And they were giving me updates regarding soundicide.
So I was giving my staff member the notes.
And then like.
My staff member.
relay the notes back to them for today.
And cause I was like.
Really stressed out.
I was really stressed out.
I was like.
Oh no I don't want to like.
I don't want to be like mean.
.
Um.
And so, like, huge shoutout to them for putting all of this together.
And also I want to say huge shoutout to Raggy.
I saw their amazing animation on Twitter.
And I was like, I need you to make the animation.
Like, I think... because I was like, she is a one-man team.
It was crazy.
Because I saw her animations on Twitter.
And I was really impressed because the animation she posted, she did all of it herself.
Like, by herself.
And I was like, I think she was the first person I ever recruited onto the team.
I was like, if I'm getting anybody, I really want Raggy to be on my team for this.
To do all of this.
I know they are also preparing for their own VTuber debut.
So please check her out.
At first she wanted to do the tomato one too.
She was like... she drew the storyboard for everything.
She drew the storyboard for the entire animation.
And then at first she was like, I think I can do the background.
And then the whole team was like, no, no don't.
You're gonna fucking kill yourself with the... by exhaustion.
You're gonna fucking...
Exhaust yourself.
No.
And then at first she was gonna be like, oh I'm gonna do the tomato.
And I was like, no.
I'm gonna recruit Saide for the tomato.
I was just like...
No.
I was like, Raggy, no.
I brought in another animator.
I think...
No.
Oh my god.
And I...
When we saw the storyboard, I was like, Raggy, I saw the storyboard.
I'm bringing Saide.
Saide has worked on my animated shorts.
Most recognizable.
The Resident Evil short.
Doki Bites.
That she did.
And I brought her in to help Raggy with doing the tomato fakeout trailer.
And Mortis brought in Will to help out with background.
To draw the backgrounds of the animation.
Yes, Raggy did...
I don't know.
You can read her Twitter and realize a lot of her I'm so tired was about the swatch.
I'm so tired.
If you read back her Twitter, it's like, I'm so tired.
It was about the swatch.
I'm glad we brought in more people.
To help out.
Because it was so much.
It was a lot of work.
Oh my god.
Because I was super open to bring more people in.
I was like, guys, are you sure we don't...
I was like, okay, bring in as many people as you guys want.
Guys, bring in as...
I'll hire more.
I'll throw more money.
Hire more people if you need to.
Oh my god.
I'm so tired.
Wow.
This is going to take forever.
So I feel really low.
I tried Sand Heyman.
But seems we can't get near him because we're on the ground.
You can't drive the more.
We have been nothing to ourselves, but I feel even better.
It's just being.
I love model.
It's like we are living in another dimension.
I thought we were living in another dimension.
Why don't you come out?
The p?.
trakaaos.
No!
And the still images of them, for those who don't use the Steam application to make animated wallpapers and stuff.
But yes, Momo was actually brought in last minute too, because one of our animators was like, we need more people to help out.
Yes.
Huge shoutout to this team.
Alright.
Sorry, there's a lot of... I have... There's a lot of creators.
Okay.
Alright!
Clea!
And... Woah, Clea did not draw both of them, by the way.
I've been blocking.
Trident did these wallpapers.
They just will be released, like I said, for free.
They did these wallpapers.
The splash art.
Cho did this one.
And Tai did the background artist for this.
Tai also did a lot of stuff.
We're writing sketches and helping with storyboards.
And everything.
I want you guys to know, the 3D team came up with the map design.
First, the environment design of the 3D world.
And then, like, you know, it was built off of that.
And then they just added more and more stuff to it.
And... Yeah.
And then we just... We had Tai draw the visual art of it as well.
Just to be like...
Just to...
Make it more, I guess, immersive when it comes to fake game.
Because there's always like the map art in the fake game portion.
In the gaming portion.
Like what the map looks like and stuff.
Yeah.
And... By the way...
Okay, I'm gonna talk about it more when we're...
Alright, so... And then this one was...
By the way, there was like... In the behind the scenes portion...
I will be... In the behind the scenes portion, I will talk more about the sketches.
Because there was a lot of concepts and stuff.
There were a shitload of concepts and everything.
Coming into designing the splash art.
So in the behind the scenes stream on Tuesday, I will go into more detail about all the concept art and everything behind the scenes.
Regarding building up this fake game that was made from this project team.
Okay, so yeah.
Porusun and Yuko did these maps.
Chiyo did all of them.
And they did all these billboards.
Did the billboard art to fill the 3D world.
So I love... I think DadSubs was my favorite.
Dad, was this your favorite too?
Was this also your favorite?
Yeah?
I don't know.
I think DadSubs was pretty funny.
And then...
That sprays!
Alright.
Yeah, we're gonna have to move over here.
So here are the item shop artists.
Honey, who did all the item shop...
Whoa.
Sorry, the alert.
All the item shop and stuff.
So, oh my god, I love it all.
I love all of them.
I think my favorite has to be...
I think my favorite has to be the...
Okay.
I think that one has to be my favorite.
By the way, a lot of the art...
We're in discussion with the artist.
But a lot... some of the artwork is gonna be made into future merch.
That will be released for pre-order on my birthday.
So like this, the sprays and...
I'm deciding stickers might be used as...
You know, be sold as actual stickers.
And the sprays might be sold as charms in the future.
Or stickers.
We're not... we're still discussing right now.
I'd love to have your ideas.
Because I'm doing this...
The next... the merch release.
The next merch drop.
To be like BattleBirds themed.
As if like you're...
As if you know we go to Apex Legends store.
Merch store.
And you buy like merch from the Apex Legends store.
Or like Blizzard shop.
And you see like these merch that they only make.
And stuff.
So we're gonna have...
One of them is like...
We're gonna have like...
T-shirt with the BattleBirds logo.
That's like one of the things I really wanna do.
Because I want you guys to pretend...
That BattleBirds is a real game.
So I love your feedback and your input.
Like in the next couple of days.
Regarding what kind of merch you wanna see BattleBirds have.
It's real to me Doki!
It's real to me!
But yes.
Like we're planning on making...
The wallpapers as like postcards maybe.
Or maybe a wall scroll tapestry.
We're still deciding.
Me and my staff team are still deciding what to be made of merch.
But I would love to have your input as well.
What you guys wanna buy.
We're gonna make the character art.
I don't know if you guys saw like the character art selection from Xie.
It's gonna be a giant diorama.
The giant diorama...
Acrylic stand.
With all the four...
With all the three?
I think three...
All the three characters select art.
And everything.
That's the one that I'm definitely sure that's gonna be...
That's gonna be made into merch.
And then here are the item shop of some of my friends.
The people I've collabed with.
So you might recognize some of them.
Also...
Yes.
I asked a few of them to do voice lines.
Okay.
I need to tell you the story of the voice line I had with Saachi.
So we were playing...
Overwatch 2 together.
I was like, yo, are you still down?
Because like I asked her.
I was like...
I was like asking Saachi.
So Saachi, I was like, hey, so like I'm doing this reveal.
Fuck, I don't know where to put myself in because it covers everybody.
I'll just be off the screen so you guys can see everything.
So...
I won't be selling merch of...
I won't be selling merch of my friends, by the way.
Because obviously like they...
They own their design.
I'm not gonna like make money off of them.
The stickers and stuff will be...
Will only be of like me and things I own.
Like...
Anyway.
So this is a funny story.
But when I was...
Like we were playing Overwatch 2 together.
And so I was like asking like, oh, do you still want to be part of...
Like I'm doing reveal on Saturday slash Sunday.
Like do you still want to...
And she's like, yeah, sure.
I was like, oh, I just need a voice line.
She's like, wait, what kind of voice line?
And then we were like playing Overwatch 2.
So she was like, what if...
I'm just gonna...
I'm just gonna like...
That is so funny.
She was like, can I just like steal an Overwatch voice line?
She was like, what if I just steal an Overwatch voice line?
And I was like, Merry Christmas.
From Kenji.
And I was just like...
I was like, do whatever you want.
I was like, no, that'll be so fun.
And then we were thinking about like, okay, maybe we shouldn't steal a voice line from Overwatch.
Because we were like looking at Lucio and Genji.
It was like, oh, I need healing.
And then we're like, Lucio, oh.
And then we almost had a voice line of her doing Doomfist's...
Doomfist's...
Which one was it?
Chivalry is dead.
And then later on, she was like, okay, maybe we shouldn't.
And if you listen back to it, she would...
She just was like, hello.
And she was like...
I was like...
I told her, I was like, I'm gonna keep that in.
I'm gonna keep the cough in.
Yeah.
Anyway, yes.
Look at all these stickers.
I don't know where to...
I'm gonna put...
Here we go.
I was like, I don't know where to put it.
Put it myself.
There's so many.
And so, yeah.
So, the ones...
DoughKing, I would definitely sell that.
They don't own a tiger.
They can't own jaguars.
This is legally distinct jaguar.
Anyway, DoughKing is gonna...
I won't sell Jack Jesus though.
Jack Jesus, I think, might be like...
Might be a bit of an iffy territory.
But I will...
I will sell the DoughKing sticker.
But yes.
The stickers you see that are not related to my friends and people I collab with.
They will not be sold as merch.
They will not be sold as merch, by the way.
What else?
Whoa!
These are the icons from the character select.
So, some of them did like friends.
Yes, my Oshii is there.
Thomas Edison.
My Oshii.
So, Black did the icons.
The icons.
The icons for the character select and my friends list.
So, I specifically requested that I wanted Thomas Edison.
My Oshii.
I was very specific.
Thomas Edison had to be on my friends list.
I don't know what...
I'm not sure what to use the icons for as merch yet.
So, that's something I'm still thinking of at the moment.
So, I don't know yet what I want to do the icons as.
But, yeah.
Like the icons that are not based off of my friends.
Maybe I'll sell Thomas Edison though.
I will sell Thomas Edison Oshii.
Like he's public domain at this point.
So, I'm legally allowed to make merch off of him.
Because he's been dead for more than a hundred years.
So, he's public domain, baby.
I can legally make merch off of him.
And finally, here are some screenshots of the maps.
The set dressing that everybody did.
It's free real estate, exactly.
The best thing about being a Vtuber is that we never die.
So, like we'll never be public domain.
And here are the maps of everything.
Oh my gosh.
Sorry.
A lot of the stream was talking about behind the scenes and projects.
Even though this isn't the behind the scenes and everything.
Oh my god.
It looks so amazing.
Yeah, Thomas Edison Web wanted me to make money off.
Exactly.
I'm only doing what my Oshii wants.
But it's so pretty.
Alright.
Back to Cowboy.
My scenes are named pretty funny.
Back to Cowboy Chatty.
Alright.
It's time for you to...
Get off.
Alright.
Here we go.
Um...
I'm trying to remember if I'm missing anything before we go to green screen time.
Am I missing anything?
Oh yeah.
I wrote a list of stuff I need to talk about.
Sorry.
I knew I...
Remember I wrote a script.
Not a script.
But like general set up of everything I need to say.
Yes!
Music will be public to everybody too!
I will make sure.
I want to upload the music itself.
But I'm trying to figure out how to upload it and stuff.
Like not how to upload.
Like I don't know how to use YouTube upload.
But more so like what kind of music.
If I want to make a music video or something.
Or like... I don't know.
I'm not sure yet.
But I will have the music available to the public as well.
Things that will be available to the public.
The 3D models of the dragoons.
Plus tomato.
Plus Retro Doki.
Um...
The...
Wallpap... The splash art as wallpapers.
Um...
And... What else did I write?
And the music.
Yes.
The... The music.
The animation high quality screenshots.
Framed by... Like the frames.
Will be shown... Given in members only.
That will be the only members exclusive that I'm gonna have.
Um...
Let's see.
Oh yeah!
Speaking of my birthday.
Birthday!
July 5th!
There's gonna be a lot of other announcements too on birthday.
So this is not just the only announcement that we're gonna have.
Oh!
Concept art!
Bam!
You're right!
Alright guys.
I need to show you guys.
Uh...
Thank you for the reminder.
I should've just looked at my...
Um...
I should've just looked at my folder.
Cause like my folder has...
Okay so...
I need to show you guys the very first concept art.
Because like it's...
Um...
So... The very first one...
Was actually with Kleia.
Um...
Cause at first I was like maybe I'll just get a new outfit.
A new like redesign slash new outfit.
Uh... With Kleia.
So...
We were debating on like a...
Okay let me...
I need to move myself a little bit.
Oh I don't wanna move myself though.
Okay.
Let me...
Move myself here.
So...
The very fir...
Oh my gosh.
Wait give me a sec.
Uh...
Oh no.
Okay.
No.
Here you go.
Alright here you go.
Alright that's better.
Alright so...
Um...
It was...
Polar bear and rat.
For the...
For the very first...
Um...
The very first concept.
We were like...
Ooh...
Maybe like...
Polar bear...
Rat themed or something.
So...
That was the...
Oh my gosh let me move...
Move myself.
No if I move myself...
Then like...
No...
I'm gonna be...
Okay so...
Um...
Originally...
I was like...
It was...
I was debating between...
Maybe I should do polar bear...
Or...
It looks like I'm trying to drink this.
But then I was like...
No that doesn't make sense cause I'm...
Doki bird.
Oh my gosh this is not gonna make sense because like I can't change Doki bird.
I...
I can't...
I can't change Doki bird.
So it wouldn't make sense.
So...
We were like...
Okay...
We...
Pivoted.
And...
Um...
My...
My new mama joined the team.
Uh...
Trying to figure something out.
And at first we were gonna be like...
Thief.
Alright.
So...
Um...
This...
Oh you're just not gonna see me.
I can't be bothered right now.
So...
Um...
I was like...
I want...
Dad to be part of me.
But then I think we had like a miscommunication.
And...
Um...
We were like...
I don't know.
Uh...
My mama thought that I just literally wanted a...
My wiener dog to be there.
And then I was like...
Maybe not.
I don't know.
I felt like too tacky for me.
To have...
Uh...
My...
Cause you can see like...
Bee was a dog walker.
I was like...
I don't know if I want to be a dog walker.
That was like my new job.
Um...
Dog walking.
But I love the hair in B!
I love the... I love the hairstyle in B.
B was our favorite hairstyle.
So we kept the B hairstyle as you guys can see.
B was like my favorite hairstyle out of all of them.
So we were like, okay, we're not gonna do dog.
But I was like, oh, I still want like dad to be representative.
And then so... so my...
My mama was like, oh, okay, which one you want to be to be dad?
I was like, I don't know.
I don't know.
So I was like, I don't really know.
It doesn't really fit.
I felt like... I guess like the crow too, but I was like, what the fuck is F?
F for dog.
And then so...
So we were talking about like concepts of...
Okay, the hats really.
It was like tuxedo mask type shit.
And then... and then... and then so then we were discussing more.
I was like, I think I want more like canine-esque type deal.
Like more canine-esque.
So then we...
Okay.
And then we're like thief too.
We were like thief and then canine and then... alright.
D is a fucking riot though.
I was like, if you want to go with D then go with D.
Okay, not gonna lie but D though!
I love.
So I saw F and I was like I love... okay, F was like, F it is.
And then we went with... we were like, I was like, I think I would like some a lighter shade and...
Okay, D is pretty funny.
I wish you could have seen...
Oh my god, I talked about this before.
But I wish you guys...
I also have known what like... Doki Amber Doge with a fucking... with like a gangster costume.
That was the funniest shit ever.
That was so good.
I wish we... you guys saw that.
You guys might remember me talking about it.
Mint's seen it.
Mint... I remember like... I remember when I showed Mint gangster Doki Amber Doge.
Like it lives rent-free in her mind.
I can't.
I can't show it.
I told you guys.
Here's the reason why I can't show it.
Because it was before Doki Amber Doge.
Is Doki Amber Doge.
Anyway, so we were talking about like what if we keep the twin tails and still go with the thief.
The thing is... okay the hardest part about rebranding and...
rebranding and everything is that I was had to make a decision on whether or not I am keeping the thief theme or going with a whole new different idea.
I decided it was a very hard decision but I decided to go with a rebrand with a new skin suit design and a new skin suit idea because I was like...
um I felt like the thief thing was like four years ago Doki.
You know it was like four years ago Doki.
The thief was originally not even based off of me.
It was actually some random...
I like took over her.
I... I did full metal alch...
...
It was alchemy.
I created this character and I...
I skin walked her so she wasn't even supposed to represent me in the first place.
And then later on she was like...
I used her as me.
I took over her form as a tomato.
And um... and so she was never really representative of how I felt like I was.
Um but she was...
Retro Doki is very close to my heart.
The skin suit is very close to my heart.
The design concept everything is very close to my heart because I've had that...
I've skin walked her for like 10 plus years.
Um...
Um so I wanted...
I was like I really wanted something that's more like me and I figured Bounty Hunter because...
Okay not...
I didn't think of Bounty Hunter.
My mama thought of Bounty Hunter because I was like I wanted something more FPS themed.
And I didn't really like the super long hair.
So I was like okay what if we go with more tomboy-esque short hair.
So uh we got to here.
This is where we got to.
Um oh my gosh you can actually see me now.
Uh this was um after that I was like um...
I was like okay um...
I want an FPS themed and uh and I wanted...
I don't like tech wear.
I straight up was like no tech wear.
So I was like I don't want tech wear.
So my mama was like well that's really difficult because what we can do is either Bounty Hunter or like military and I didn't go with one because...
Um...
It looked too much like Shibuya Hal.
So I was like...
I didn't want...
Look I did want to do like what Shibuya Hal does but in like NA western scene.
But I was like I don't want to be actually Shibuya Hal.
I don't want to be actually Shibuya Hal.
So um...
Left eye patch.
Anyway so I was just like okay we're gonna go I love and I really liked the uh I really really really liked the Bounty Hunter theme but you can see that we changed more so like cowboy-esque because another thing I...
I felt like the jacket okay it's gonna be so annoying.
I felt like the jacket having the collars up would I felt it was too boyish like I would be a tomboy but I still didn't want to be like super duper boyish.
And everything so I was like um I and I felt like the the jacket thing is like it would cover the screen too much it like it might cover the screen too much because it was long and I was like thinking I was thinking like um okay let's have the collar down and um I want to keep it keep it more simple.
I need I wanted to have it more simple as well because I don't like it.
I don't like having super over designed stuff I just want to have like a brand that was like that's me like I don't want to be like super duper over design and stuff like that so I like uh kept it more simple and everything I also had uh uh oh yeah I meant I don't know you were here earlier but we were talking about remember gangster gangster dad wait no it was like rapper dad.
You remember gangster dad?
I don't know if you saw the other I I don't know you were there earlier while showing like earlier concepts of of of dad but like I was talking about yeah I wish you guys saw rapper dad I don't know what really it was.
I always think about him sometimes.
Anyway, I also had Kley a help out as well and give like her take on like bounty hunter and stuff.
Um this was when we decided to do like a smaller jacket as well cause I felt like long jackets, like like bounce.
This was a little bit overdone.
We don't really see like short jackets and stuff.
So, Clea was also...
giving like insight and stuff on like different concepts and everything.
And...
Hey guys, be saucier.
So, Clea was also giving like input and stuff for us as well.
Like giving us what like...
cheat things would look good as a bounty hunter.
And then we also have this as well.
We played around a lot with stuff.
It was so difficult.
Because like... I feel like designing, having another kit... like just having a new skin suit is such a difficult process in general.
So, we had these from Clea.
And then we were given this as well.
I was like, no.
I saw this.
I was like, I don't know.
Now it looks like I'm showing off.
I felt like... I felt like I was showing off at that point.
So, I was like... I was straight up was like, no.
I know.
Too bright.
I was like, too bright.
I can't.
That's... it's too bright.
I feel like...
it's not... I don't know.
I don't know if I like this.
Yeehaw.
I don't know.
And then in the end... in the end, we got to...
This is... oh wait.
No.
This is not the end.
Because we had a different clip too.
We had... dad was...
a little darker... darker fur.
And then we had different clip because we thought like, oh, maybe like a... a bullet arrow.
But it didn't look as good as I thought.
So, we scrapped that.
But all of this stayed the same.
All of that stayed the same.
Just not this.
It was a different... she gave us the X hair clip earlier.
And then... I was just like... actually, it doesn't look as good.
I thought...
I was like, what about the bullet arrow?
A bullet arrow.
And then we saw that and I was like, Ah!
They look as good as I expected!
So we scrapped that.
And went straight back to the default.
So yeah, anyway.
A lot of the inspiration I gave regarding notes I gave for inspiration and stuff.
I was like, I really want...
Like, I sent designs of the Mandalorian.
Mandalorian.
Sniper from Team Fortress 2.
Cassidy from Overwatch.
And...
Look, this was later, okay?
I know some of you guys were like, Oh, were you trying to copy the ghoul from Fallout?
I gave that later.
After we had the initial concept.
Okay?
I did give the ghoul at a later point.
But that was later in the process.
It was later in the process, okay?
Because I know the ghoul.
Yeehaw.
But yes.
Those were like the design concepts I gave my mama.
Regarding like how I would like to see in vision.
Bounty.
Bounty hunter.
And stuff like that.
And this is how I was born.
Not...
Wait, no.
Not born.
My skin suit was made.
This is how I've always been born.
But this is how my skin suit was created.
It was a super long process.
A lot of back and forth.
A lot of like, I'm scared.
A lot of like, oh my god.
I'm so fucking scared.
I don't know how they're going to react.
Oh.
Let me see.
But yes.
It is going to be a...
Okay.
Just you reminded me.
I will show you guys the reference sheet.
Okay?
I will show you guys the reference.
Guys.
I'll show you...
All right.
Okay.
So this is...
I'll be posting this on Twitter later.
But...
This is the first reference sheet where you see the backside.
The design on the back.
The design on the side.
And everything.
No!
Stop.
And then...
This!
There you go.
You see that?
Right here.
That's a bump right here.
Okay.
Funny story.
It was...
There was originally no bump.
And then I was like, can we have a little...
Can we have a little...
Can we add...
Okay.
I specifically...
I specifically requested.
Because there was zero bump at first.
And then I was like, can we have...
Can we add two more letters in there?
Can we at least go up two more letters?
That's all I ask.
I just want to go up two more letters.
If you guys need extra eyes, do not worry.
But right here... right here...
Whoa!
Sorry!
Sorry, I got a little overzealous here.
Okay, let me like fucking make sure everything is the same.
Alright, here we go.
Just so you guys know, right here... here you go.
See that?
You see that?
That used to be like actually nothing.
That actually...
That used to be like nothing.
And then I was like, can it not be nothing?
I specifically... I specifically requested I want to go up like two letters at least.
At least two letters.
So...
I swear, I will show you guys how...
No, actually I don't have the file.
You're so lucky I don't have the file.
I didn't like download it again.
But there was a bump!
There is a bump now!
Anyway, anyway, here's the...
Whoa, let me grab the reference sheet.
It's pretty...
It's pretty big here.
Okay, let's see.
Whoa!
Okay, I need to like fix this.
Alright, so...
It's a big reference sheet too.
Um...
Yes.
Alright, so here is what it looks like.
Um...
I have this on Twitter as well.
So you guys can see everything.
So there's dad over there.
And then there's all my accessories and everything.
It's very bird themed.
Um...
Yes!
Medium is good too!
It could have been nothing!
But at least we got medium!
It's all natural.
Yeah.
Um...
You guys are watching too much anime.
You think that's not medium.
Look, we're not here with like...
Like helium balloons.
Okay?
It's not high school...
Was it the zombie fucking...
The one where like she dodges the bullet and the boobs flap.
And dodges the bullet.
That's not that.
Hahahaha!
Anyway...
Um...
Let's see.
Anyway, so here is the reference sheet for everything.
So...
I will post this on Twitter later.
If I'm not dead.
After the stream.
Hahahaha!
Um...
I think... Is that everything I want to talk about?
Before we do green screen?
Uhhhh...
I'm trying to remember.
I'm trying to remember...
If there's anything else...
I want to talk about before we go to...
Uh... green screen.
Uh...
I'll give you guys booba tomato!
This is the only jiggle fixes we're gonna get today.
Hahahaha!
I'll give you guys... I'm gonna give you guys...
Booba tomato soon.
Okay guys?
Give me a sec.
I need to remember how to fix it.
Because I... I...
I like... um...
Edit the physics.
So that... I took away the bone...
I took away the...
Um...
What do they put when they like...
Do like plastic surgery and they added more booba.
What's that called?
Implants?
I took away the implants that...
My doctor gave me.
That made me super jiggly.
Hahahaha!
I took away the implants.
So I'm not as jiggly anymore.
The silicone.
Yeah.
My plastic surgeon tried to give me silicone on my tomato.
On my true form.
And then I was like, oh maybe not.
And then I had the silicone removed from my tomato form.
Um...
Anyway.
My green screen.
There's so many...
There's like so many things too.
So it's like...
Ah!
Okay we'll do tomato first.
Actually I'll show you guys the new tomato stuff.
Give me a sec.
I need to like grab it.
Hahahaha!
Actually I don't know.
I don't know.
Um...
I need to like look at my settings real fast.
I need to look at my hotkeys.
What are my hotkeys?
Okay.
One, two, three...
Five...
Six... Okay.
Why did I skip two?
Do I not have a...
One, two, three, four...
Why did I skip four?
I don't even have a four.
Okay.
Alright.
Sorry my...
Purple screen.
Alright.
Here.
Alright so this is my new form.
And I can do this.
Hahahaha!
Okay anyway.
Anyway.
I have retro...
I have like...
Cha cha cha!
Hahahaha!
I have...
I have retro doki hat.
And then yee-haw!
Yeah cha cha cha!
Hahahaha!
Okay but I also...
I also have um...
Pien!
Hahahaha!
No...
No bitches.
Hahahaha!
By the way.
Rice added that...
Added that themselves.
I didn't request for it.
Um...
Rice added it themselves.
So they like...
Stuffed some eye implants into me as well.
My plastic surgeon gave me some eye implants.
Um...
And then I think this one is my favorite.
This one is my favorite.
Now I'm gaming.
Hahahaha!
I requested this.
I was like I want RGB!
Hahahaha!
I...
I specifically asked for RGB.
I don't know how to make it stop!
How do I make it stop?
Oh okay I stopped it.
Okay I didn't know how to make it stop.
I was so scared.
Okay let me see if I can remember how to Max it out.
Okay give me a sec.
I need you guys to see the booba.
Um... what is it?
Which one was it?
It was like the physics.
Arm.
No it's not arm.
It's... was it body move?
Hahahaha!
I'm trying to remember.
No!
Okay.
Okay give me a sec.
I need to look at...
Uh...
Oh my god which one was it?
Oh there we go!
Physics settings!
Okay.
Oh there we go!
Was it... okay I think I was at...
Was it this one?
No.
Okay that's not it.
Guys give me a sec.
I'm trying to remember.
Let me look at... guys it's time to look at my emails.
Hahahaha!
Let me... um...
Give me a sec.
Uh...
Let me... let me look at my...
It's time to look at my emails.
Hahahaha!
Actually I don't...
I didn't know you guys wanted to see it!
I should have known you guys wanted to see it.
Alright.
Give me a sec guys.
I need to figure out which one...
Oh there it is!
Okay guys watch this.
I figured it out guys.
I figured it out.
Okay.
I feel like...
Physics settings.
Okay.
Oh they're all at...
One...
Uh...
One... One...
Because I put it at zero.
Uh... One...
Hahahaha!
Oh my god!
I'm maxing it out!
Not maxing it out.
I'm putting it on default because I had to like...
I had to put it all at zero.
Okay guys.
Are you guys ready?
Hahahaha!
Oh my god!
Okay.
Hahahaha!
I put the silicone back in.
It's not that bad.
It's because I'm not moving as much.
Now you know why.
Hahahaha!
The tomato ate right.
Okay wait.
If I move like...
Harder...
You guys will see it.
Hahahaha!
Okay no.
It's because...
Okay.
It's because like I turned it like...
A bit down.
You guys want to see it...
Okay.
You guys want to see the original physics?
Oh don't worry.
I'll show you guys the original physics.
Now you'll know why.
This was...
Guys.
This was the original.
Hahahaha!
I toned it down.
Now this was the original settings.
Hahahaha!
This tomato is not doing so well.
Guys.
Plastic surgery was a mistake.
Hahahaha!
At least somebody is getting some jiggles.
Okay.
Um.
Now make it RGB.
You're right.
Hahahaha!
Wow!
Take your meds!
Hahahaha!
Okay.
Anyway.
I gotta fucking fix myself.
I gotta.
Um.
Let me fix myself real fast.
But that was... That was the original.
I'll fix the... I'll fix myself later.
I'm too tired right now.
I wanna... I'm too tired to fix myself.
Um.
Okay.
Now we're back here.
Alright.
I put back my skin suit back on.
Veggie tails!
Alright.
So.
Screenshot time!
Like I said I can do...
Hahahaha!
I think this is my... This one is my favorite.
And also...
Hmm.
The lip bite.
Hahahaha!
That one's also my favorite.
It's so hard to give you a screenshot cause there's so many expressions I can make now.
Like take your camera.
And there's this one.
I love that one too.
That one's my favorite expression too.
Hahahaha!
Um.
And then...
Hmm.
Hahahaha!
Um.
Try to think of other stuff I can do.
I can do so much.
I can do like...
Hmm.
And...
Hahahaha!
Um.
And then obviously there's the...
There's dad.
Dad's above me here.
Yay!
Woo!
There's dad right here.
If you just want screenshots of dad.
Here he is.
He's just chilling.
He's just...
He's just having a good time.
Hahahaha!
Yeah!
There he is.
Mm-hmm.
And then there he goes.
And then there's...
Dragons?
Did you guys like the debut?
Did you guys like it?
Hahahaha!
And then there's the one with tears.
Did you guys like it?
Really?
Really guys?
Again?
Oh my god.
You guys liked it?
And...
Also, oh I can... the red eye... the aimbot.
Aimbot's on.
Legal aimbot.
Sorry.
Legal aimbot on.
So please don't report me because it's biologically on me.
There's no Clara shit here.
It's legal aimbot.
Hahahaha!
Uh...
And... oh wait.
Numbers?
Math?
Where am I?
Which left?
Which north?
Hahahaha!
Uh... and then...
Woo!
Oh!
Oh I like this face too.
Hahahaha!
Uh... oh my god there's...
I hope you're taking all the screenshots!
We're going so fast!
It's like modeling, you know?
Like modeling you're supposed to make like 10 poses per minute or something.
Cause it's like...
I hope you guys are taking very fast screenshots cause I have so many expressions.
I'm not used to it.
I'm not used to having so many expressions.
That like I have to go by so fast.
And then...
Um...
Oh my god.
What's that?
Did you guys hear that?
Guys I'm gonna like...
Never remember to use any of these.
Hahahaha!
Oh and... oh yeah my favorite one.
This is my favorite.
You see the hair physics a lot better too.
Hahahaha!
I can fight you with my ne...
Oh it's like those giraffe fights!
Okay you know like giraffes that's how they fight?
They swing their necks at each other and be like...
Uh!
Hahahaha!
That's how they fight!
That is how they fight!
And then normal sparkle and be like...
Wait for me?
And then...
Oh yeah jacket off.
The jacket comes off!
Oh yeah and then you see like you know...
My shirt is a little ripped there and...
stuff.
The jacket comes...
on!
And...
Aviators...
Yeah!
I have my aviators now...
on!
Hahahaha!
I can make so many expressions!
I don't even need toggles!
Okay and then also...
Gun!
That's really it.
That's all it does.
Gun!
You want a screenshot of just gun?
Hahahaha!
Just the gun!
I'm gonna whip my gun out!
Alright and then...
The frowning one...
Wait did I fuck it up?
...
Quick she can't aim right now!
Oh yeah finally...
Dead inside.
Yes dead inside.
Wait no that's...
Bad.
Don't take a screenshot of that.
Wait no I... I... I...
I've seen those.
Hahahaha!
Alright and then...
Uh...
Shit there was like something else.
I think that's... Is that everything?
Is that all?
Alright.
Requests?
Is there any requests?
Alright here's the full body too.
Guys any requests you guys wanna do?
For your screenshots?
Uh...
Don't use that as reference.
That's not...
Don't use that expression as reference.
Uhhh...
Upside... No.
Not upside down.
But you can just like flip it yourself.
Uh... Aimbot eyes or glasses?
Okay.
Glasses.
Oh winking!
Hahahaha!
Hahaha!
Oh it's better with the right eye.
Hahahaha!
Long neck with dad.
Okay.
Alright give me a sec.
I need to like prep that.
Wooo!
Hahahaha!
Alright.
Alright I'll do three more requests chat.
Three more requests guys.
Uh...
What else do you guys... What are expressions you guys...
What dad's gonna throw up?
Hahaha!
Upsies!
Oh sparkler?
Hahaha!
No!
You're not getting that.
You're not...
I'm not doing that for two dollars.
What the fuck?
Hahaha!
Um...
No!
Oh sparkle wink without the jacket?
Yeah we can do that.
With no jacket.
There you go.
The fries!
Wink!
Hahaha!
Uh...
Will you do it for us?
Okay.
Yeah I would actually.
Was it...
Was it with...
Hahaha!
Okay.
Alright.
Hahaha!
No!
That didn't happen.
That didn't happen guys.
Alright.
One more.
One last one.
I'll do one more request.
Uh...
I'll do one more request guys.
Look, a bounty hunter's gotta eat.
Okay?
It's not an easy job.
It's not...
It's not an easy job guys.
It did already got the...
Someone go delete FBI!
FBI if you're watching me right now, FBI.
Uh...
Get this agent to delete his screenshot right now.
Get the FBI agent to delete his screenshot.
Um...
Alright.
What do I do?
Red eye with left wink?
Okay.
That?
Hahaha!
Alright.
Alright!
Let's go back.
Green screen...
Purple screen over.
Purple screen has ended.
We go back now.
But yeah!
That was great.
That was...
That was a lot.
Hahaha!
I had... Honestly that was a...
Oh my god!
My nerves!
I'm not as nervous and anxious anymore.
I felt like...
I felt like... Um...
Honestly felt like I was...
Redebuting all... I mean technically it is...
Redebuting.
I felt like I was debuting all over again too.
So...
Oh my gosh!
I was so nervous.
Really a huge shout out to...
My project team.
For getting all of that...
For like getting my vision out there.
And...
Being able to...
Work on all of it.
And...
Even though we were a day late.
I think...
The way it was worth it.
And it was...
It was...
Definitely for them and for me...
One of the most stressful projects we've ever done.
Hahaha!
Because it was incredibly ambitious!
I've never been able to do something this ambitious before.
When it comes to like producing it.
And...
Like I said...
It's because of your support guys.
That I was able to do something like this.
Be able to plan something like this.
And afford to do something like this.
So thank you Dragoons for your support.
And being able to...
Help me fund...
This passion project that I did.
And...
Yeah but please check out my new merch.
From...
From my mama.
That they did.
My new acrylic stand.
That you can pre-order now.
I love the visual art.
This is going to be my new...
Key visuals now.
So I'm going to be using this for like...
If I'm guesting at any places or something.
And they need a key visual.
I'll definitely be using this as the main art.
For stuff like that.
Because I always wanted a key visual art.
Um...
And yes.
I couldn't have done it without all of you guys.
I couldn't have done it without you guys.
Because I have been able to...
You know...
Be able to afford to do stuff like this.
And be able to...
Be able to you know...
Do these passion projects.
And...
Be able to entertain you guys.
And have fun with all of you.
So thank you Dragoons!
Thank you all for the super chats.
Thank you all for the...
For the memberships.
Joining the tomato farm.
And supporting me!
I hope this...
I hope this new rebrand...
Was worth it for you guys!
Because I know...
It's very different from Retro Doki.
And I...
I just really wanted to...
Merge...
Past and present together.
Into something that I felt...
Was more like me.
And I'm so happy to be able to...
Work with my mama.
To do all of that.
And...
And yeah I was really surprised.
I remember sending that email.
I was like...
Are you open too?
And they were like yes!
And I was so happy.
And we worked very hard together.
With Clea.
And Celia.
Celia actually gave input as well.
Gave input as well when it came to this design.
And also my artist friends like Poki.
And Poki and Gigi.
Who helped me a lot.
I actually...
Leaked the model to them and asked...
Their advice as well.
Regarding like...
Regarding like what to do.
And stuff.
And...
Lots of work!
I was so scared.
I was so nervous.
I was so anxious.
But it's over!
It's over now!
We ripped the bandaid off.
And this is what I look like now!
Yay!
Yes!
I think that's really...
All I really want to say.
I hope you guys had a...
Great time today.
Great time watching.
And had a lot of fun.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
As always everyone.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me.
Head to bed.
Because you deserve it!
Oh yes!
Before I forget.
I will be a guest.
At Yu Sun's tour.
In Hong Kong.
Yes.
I think I'm singing.
I think.
I should know by now.
It's in August.
I think I'm...
I am singing.
Yes.
It would be pretty awkward if I wasn't.
I'll be...
I'll also be at AVCon in Adelaide.
And I'll be as...
Bounty Hunter Doki.
So I'll be Bounty Hunter Doki.
At all my future conventions.
Unless there's like...
I feel a little quirky.
And I swap between things.
But we'll see.
AVCon will be the first time I'll be using Bounty Hunter Doki.
But yes!
I'll see you guys Tuesday.
For behind the scenes.
Bye everybody!
Bye!